for letting us use this facility and
important to note this is a state
meeting the county doesn't really have
anything to do with it they were just
nice enough to let us have this space
the purpose of this is to receive input
about redistricting in other words local
knowledge that's why we came out here
what do you like what do you not like do
you wish things were different do you
hope things stay the same
that type of granular knowledge is what
we hope to receive from you so with that
i'll open up house sierra house hearing
senator greg
and i open the senate hearing first
thing i would like to do is
recognize senator khan who was the
senator for this district and thank you
for coming to welcome us
uh i am senator james gray i am the
uh chair of the senate special committee
on registered king i'm also the chair of
election law
and they give me a few other jobs
and with that
senator i'm senator donna soucy i
represent senate district 18 which is
manchester's wards five through nine and
the town of litchfield and i look
forward to hearing from you this evening
i am representative paul bergeron from
nashua
ward 2 and i'm a member of the house
election law as well as a member of this
committee
i'm connie lane i represent uh ward 2 in
concord and
i'm on this committee and on the
election law committee
i'm lucy weber i represent uh cheshire
one which is walpole merlin chesterfield
in kingsdale and i serve on this
committee in health human services and
elderly affairs
and welcome to cheshire county
i'm marjorie smith i represent durham
and madbury in the new hampshire house
which i've done for i think 114 years
give or take
um close to that at least
and i serve on the house judiciary
committee in addition to serving on
this
special redistricting committee
hi i'm representative bob nguyen i'm
from windham new hampshire
i serve on the redistricting committee
committee
my name is matt wilhelm i represent
manchester awards one two and three in
the house and uh serve on this committee
and state federal relations veterans
appearance and i always forgot to tell
everybody who i am i apologize for that
i am representative steven smith and
your northern neighbor literally uh
seldom county and represent backworth
charlestown goshen langdon webster and
washington
senator i had one more thing this uh
senate hearings do not allow oil booming
clapping
it is inappropriate the
testimony that you give and others
should be
listened to
and
you will be gavel if you start to clap
or boo or whatever so
please
you know adhere to that
all right thank you everyone and with
that let's get going
uh
people that are addressing the committee
the step up to the election there
mr bowers of grantham
thank you um
but i am from
your neighbor to the north uh slow
encounter
i want to correct a new statement that
has been repeated in previous meetings
and among the general public
it is not true that the new hampshire
constitution requires that towns that
are large enough to have their own
representative
it's all district c
that's the quotation from
minutes of a previous meeting
as are these others it is not true
that new one is constitutional
guaranteed its own district
representative or that canaan is legally
entitled to its own representative
district
it is not true
that in 2011
152 towns were eligible
but 62 of those towns did not receive
their own house district
violating the constitution as amended
what the new hampshire constitution says
is
when the population of any counter order
according to last federal census
is within a reasonable deviation from
the ideal population
for one or more representative seats
the tower war shall have its own
district of one or more representative
seats
the key phrase is reasonable deviation
a town is not entitled to its own
district
just by being large
its population must be within a
reasonable deviation of the idea
the one that's population is 4 400 which
is a deviation of 28 percent
far beyond what anybody can see that
considers reasonable
canaan's deviation is 10
which is beyond the guideline for reason
in 2011 there were 152 towns with large
population
but most of them
were beyond reasonable deviations
i estimate that about 30 tabs were
within reasonable deviations
if you look at the legislative history
of the constitutional amendment the
voters passed in 2006
you will see that the bill as introduced
said that when a town award has enough
inhabitants
[Music]
it shall have its own district
that was the bill as introduced
that is not the bill that was passed by
the general court and passed by the
voters the language the voters approved
was the language about with a reasonable
deviation
in cheshire
walpole's population deviation is 5.5
which is barely outside the guidelines
reasonable
personally i think that's a very
reasonable stretch from the guideline
and very justifiable under redistricting
case law
the keen wards
deviate 34
from ideal population
they are not entitled to their own
districts even though they're quite a
bit larger
than
the size of a
an ideal district
i urge the committee to look at the
actual language of the constitution
not what various people think it says
please do not attempt to give every
large town its own district
i have seen maps that started out by
making every large town its own district
but then they had to face unreasonable
deviations
and they did it by creating
large and ugly floaterial districts
that defeated the intent
to have locally elected representatives
do attempt
to eliminate the huge material districts
from the entire map now cheshire does
not have
any huge material districts
but next door hillsborough has some
really ugly floaters and my county
sullivan has one
pretty ugly
plateau
so please do attempt to eliminate the
materials
except for a case like lebanon where um
the wards are such a size that each ward
could be its own district and then a
floatarium would be that large covering
the entire
city
that's a good use of so tyrion's
but again some of the ones we have right
now are just
ugly
please do attempt to create small
districts that meet the intent of the
constitution
even if you slightly stretch the
deviation guidelines as i said for
wallfall thank you
thank you next up
uh i can't quite make out the first
thing looks like harvey from
chesterfield oh i'm sorry i must online
i thought that was just a champion
i'm sorry
from rich oh wait written testimony yes
or no uh
jeff
stickler
no i don't have anybody
um
i'm from ranch
um which is many of you know
extremely divided
[Music]
and yet in
the last election
[Music]
and no gerrymandering
to
deserve our own
representative
[Music]
we have a school district in jaffrey
it's not in
in our districts
um
[Music]
physical
resources
um
you know so
also when it comes to the
senatorial and the
[Music]
medical
um
so we need a representative that
represents ranch represents us
not someone who represents an urban area
[Music]
or world needs
so i ask you
to take that very much into
consideration of doing this
redistricting
no gerrymandering please we can pull
this together you guys can do this
thank you very much for your time
thank you
senator khan
i have to ask you senator i know it's
spelled differently with your last name
and captain kirk going up you couldn't
leverage to ride on that rocket
that just would have been awesome
my family
[Laughter]
[Music]
so thank you committee members for
coming to cheshire county and keene it's
a pleasure to welcome you
uh
i want to thank uh our county
administrator chris coates chris maybe
wave
this is a fabulous facility that they
maintain here and
i really appreciate your
offering this for public conversation
thank you
um
and uh i'm pleased to address you
tonight i i
now in my third term in the state senate
uh
and have been in the region for 33 years
um
what i think you can note i'm going to
start with the senate
talk about the
then the executive council and
relative to cheshire county we're a
county of 77 000 people because
76 000 something
uh according to the
census table which is handed out tonight
um
[Music]
and each senate district you would think
uh will have between 55
sixty thousand uh
people that it represents
um
you would think then that cheshire
county would be represented in the
senate by two
senators
or two senate districts
that's not the case
currently
while
i represent 15 of the 23 towns in
cheshire county
the remaining eight are peeled off into
three other senate districts
um so there is
very little
uh in
influence
in those other three senate districts
of those towns it happens that in the
second
that senator ward is from cheshire
county
and a small town
in her senate district
which is largely in sullivan's county
and hillsborough an odd district
um
nonetheless my point is
uh i would recommend to the body that
you think of cheshire economy as falling
into two senate districts
uh so that the
common interest
of the county uh is
represented in two districts
um
and to carry that a little bit further
uh
the school districts that are
represented
in cheshire county would be the keene
school district
uh the monadnock school district uh
which happens to line up in two senate
districts
um kinsdale and winchester and fall
mountain they're all in my
senate district
also
having towns in cheshire county would be
the conval or contoucast valley school
district and the jaffrey rings school
district
and so i would offer to you that
those seven school districts
are
a body of interest
that could be worked with to
try to find how to
define
two senate districts
with those seven common uh taxing
districts represented in their school
therapies
to shift from the state senate and its
composition uh
i address next the executive council
district
cheshire county with its 76 plus
thousand
citizens
sullivan county
county 43 000
represent an area that i consider to be
western new hampshire
so representative smith representative
weber we share this interest in this
region with the state
uh that has
as we've noted uh through recent storms
uh common disasters uh common rivers
uh and common interest
uh
that
145 150 000 people will not make up an
executive council district but
stretching that executive council
district beyond rep
or interstate 93
is beyond the power of reasoning
i would
ask that the
if your body
find
a way of defining a executive council
district that has
more geographic
commonality
than the
salamander district that district 2
currently represents going from the
vermont
border to the sea
and then
finally
relative to the house i think there are
a lot of complications uh trying to
divvy out 400
seats uh and
i what i i can
observe uh from those seats is that some
will represent 3 000
voters but some will represent 24 000
voters
some are
within the city and some
have a very large stretch of land and
even here in cheshire county
that make up
multiple towns and large geographic
areas
i guess i
my biggest takeaway that i hope i leave
is that
the need for some public feedback on
house districting
after your process i think is really
important
people need to see some transparency and
have some opportunity to comment on the
recommendations of your body relative to
house districts
and i hope you'll be able to incorporate
more informed
commentary
at that time
so
thank you very much again
glad to answer any questions but i'm
appreciative of the body looking for
public input i'm glad
thank you my name is ian burke i grew up
in the town of sullivan which is in
cheshire county uh and now i live in
keynes
i'm working with the open democracy now
tech team to better understand
the relationship between different
regional representative
representation
maps and
other districts and communities that
exist in new hampshire
i think that representation works best
when our representatives can easily
connect with their constituents and also
when our representatives share
their
constituents interests by using the same
blitz of water
shopping in the same stores
dealing with the same weather disasters
dealing with the same property tax rates
well i hope that
excuse me
i feel that redistricting for party and
electoral advantage
marginalizes actual communities in favor
of shared national party affiliation
and i think that that makes a
less effective legislation and less
effective
state government
i hope that
in future redistricting cycles new
hampshire can move to an independent
redescription process
but i hope that in the current cycle the
committees find maps that
put existing communities and their
shared interests
first above
political advantage thanks
thank you
[Music]
6 26.
that
was amazing so we don't have anyone else
signed up to speak
and this is kind of deja vu because in
coast county
within the spinning distance of the
canadian border we ended at 6 26 and i
thought that was too quick
so i'm going to do the same thing in
case somebody's late and recess until 6
and at that time we'll see if anyone
else is ready to go and if not then
so we're
recess until 6 40.
i was a great guy
[Applause]
[Music]
if you are watching this on video i
would like to know how to contact the
committee to share your input
go to the general court website
new hampshire house it's a tab right up
at the top and you'll find a link that
says committees
under that you'll find standing
committees the special committee on
redistricting we are some of them
and right there you can find the
committee website with uh notes and
documents from previous meetings
when we get some work done those plans
will be uploaded there you can email the
committee with one link there
and also you can always contact your
local representative and ask them to
provide input to us
there are 400 of us that's what we're
the for
the process
we're holding these input sessions in
all ten counties we hope to receive you
know local input from there
the stuff about range was great nuggets
like that things that we may not know
because we're not from there we will
take that back to concord we will
apply the map
to the maps because math is our god in
that case
and then
in november this committee will vote on
a recommendation
it it'll be public sometime in january
or february house bills pass over the
senate there'll be more hearings so it
doesn't get all wrapped up right in
november there are many months more to
this process
uh no um
getting to the senate page
uh you can do it from the senate website
but right at the general court website
there is a link on the right hand side
for both the house and the senate
web pages
remember these are going to be regular
bills
and it will go through the normal bill
process
in the committees so
there will be
time for you to come in
uh it may not be in the districts
but uh there will be time for you to
come in
alrighty
and with that we have representative
harvey of chesterfield
mr chair thank you for giving me a
chance to reconsider and actually
talking in front of the committee
welcome to cheshire county
i actually live in chesterfield so
although uh i'm probably a little biased
i'm sure this is the best county in the
entire state
i represent cheshire district one which
is chesterfield
uh walpole hinsdale and westmoreland
some people might consider considering a
little bit of a larger district
i don't
because it's been my home now for almost
40 years
and as i've heard some people say it's
important for districts to share
uh some commonalities we are rural and
we definitely share the connecticut
river in fact we're sometimes called
four river towns so
it's important
for me
and my constituents to keep us together
because we do have that big um that big
river that we share
between all the towns
um i've been a representative for six
years now um
i've had this opportunity but i'm
delighted to have that and in the six
years i've never heard any constituents
from any of those towns complain about
the way our cheshire district one is
organized
and surely
people are very good at complaining
surely if there has been a problem
sometime in six years i would have
gotten an email that said representative
that i needed to think about this and
i'm not i'm not receiving that um
it works for us
here in cheshire district one because a
lot of our uh projects our projects
although they might be in one town or
the other
they affect all of us for instance the
maplewood nursing home affects all of
the uh towns in cheshire district forum
the hinsdale bridge
was important to everybody
broadband in chesterfield was
a model for the broadband and welcome
these are not individual projects
they're district projects we are one
district cheshire one
um
our constituents can easily travel
across and from all the way from
hinsdale to walpole
in fact i kind of doubtly even know that
they're you know going between uh
districts that oftentimes you heard when
we talk about verdicts chocolates
and everything in between so
so they they do uh travel from one end
to the other very easily and
it's not a hardship it's not a problem
for them
i've heard people tonight saying that
there are um some districts that have
problems and they need to be fixed and
i i get that there may be those nuggets
that the chair was referring to cheshire
district one is not wonderful it's not
broken it works well our constituents
like it please don't try to fix it
thank you
representative birch
westmoreland
i'm paul burch from west milan also from
cheshire one
which i weren't speaking after my good
friend kathy harvey
she
said pretty well what i wanted to say
and said it probably better than i can
the first speaker who spoke today
addressed one issue that was close to my
heart because he made reference to the
provision in the new hampshire
constitution and suggested that it was
not mandatory
that towns of a certain size have their
own representative and that is true and
i'm glad someone else picked up on that
the
new hampshire supreme court dealt with
this issue
after the last reinforcement 10 years
ago and said there's a hierarchy
of
values
in doing redistricting the top value is
the federal which is one person one vote
below that are the
new hampshire constitutional values
which include
the
towns should get
within a proper deviation
uh representation by
size but also such concepts it's not
dividing
uh
towns into different districts paying
attention to uh natural formations such
as mountains and rivers and alike
so there's a number of factors that go
into uh redistricting and i'm sure that
this committee is more than familiar
with uh with those um i have to second
what uh representative barbara said
about how well things work in uh gesture
one and that goes to the other issue and
that is commonality of interests that is
not in the constitution statutory and
therefore it doesn't quite have the same
protection
as
the constitutional provisions
but i don't know a single granite stater
that doesn't appreciate commonality of
interests when they get together to
decide how money should be spent how
projects should be approved or not
approved
and how
issues that affect them and their
families should be built
commonality interest is so important and
i remember when redistricting happened
10 years ago i wasn't in the legislature
that but i tend to meet it similar to
this
and there was a lot of discussion about
how to fashion
the districts and i have to say even
before i was in the legislature
that putting the four river towns
together
by far
made the most sense
for this neck of the woods
because the ecology and the economics
of the connecticut river
are
so
important
and they are so linked
to the well-being of the people who live
on both sides of the river
so whether it's
waste in the river
whether it's
commerce and the river
whether it's transportation and the
river
it makes a big deal to those who live
on the river
and it's not just that i can
sit on my back porch and look across the
river and see bernie sanders for vermont
it's that we go back and forth and
people who live
on one side of the river
work at walmart and instead and things
like that
so yes it does work
and i guess the final comment i want to
say
is the echo what kathy harvey said is
most granite staters believe if it ain't
broke don't fix
but if it is broken
and it is broken in parts and anybody
who looks at the executive council
seat for district 2
uh knows it's broken
and fix the broken parts
but don't try to
try to fix the unbroken parts uh just
because
you got a chance to do it
so you've heard from two of the four
people in in the county
in the district and i will echo in my
ten years of the legislature
i have yet to have a single
constituent tell me
that they wish our district were
made up difficult
they may have different views should be
represented that's a different question
thank you
okay
like to thank our hosts in cheshire for
allowing us to have the space
the staff for making sure that it was
live streamed and that will be archived
to be publicly available um it will be
on youtube
a day or two
we thank you for your input and with
that i'll close the house hearing